so first of all welcome welcome to the
first Columbia University Libraries
comic symposium comic New York my name
is Karen green I'm the graphic novels
librarian although I was originally
hired as the ancient and medieval
history and religion librarian so I hold
to interesting and in many ways
complementary positions here before I
say anything else I want to send out
huge thanks to my fellow organizers of
this event Jeremy Dalbert who is here's
the director of the Institute for Israel
and Jewish Studies and Danny finger off
who stand up Danny who many of you may
know as a long time writer and editor of
comics and chronicler of comics and now
the senior VP of education at the Museum
of comic and cartoon art which you
should all join I'm a member of the
board of trustees so I'm just going to
say a few things and then we'll get
rolling and I want to start off by
making an observation when Lee Bollinger
became the president of Columbia ten
years ago his first official speaking
engagement was with the library's
professional staff and he said to us
among many other things that one of our
challenges would be to identify
disciplines areas of collection for four
topics that maybe we didn't even know
about yet so we had to think very far
into the future about how we would shape
the collection I'm not sure that when he
said that he had comics in mind but I
have to say that since starting the
graphic novels collection here in 2005 I
feel like I have at least done a bit too
to fulfill that pledge and so here we
are at Comic New York i mentioned that i
am a librarian for medieval history and
religion so i could say that this event
has to Genesis stories but
in homage to the context I will say this
event has two origin stories and it's a
tale of two Chris's one of them being
Chris couch wave Chris couch is a
Columbia PhD who is now a professor at a
variety of institutions including SVA
downtown and who contacted a few people
nearly two years ago i'd say thinking
that we should talk about a potential
event big comics event here at columbia
and he called together a group of people
i think the first person he contacted
was Danny finger off and Chris and Danny
together called together about I don't
know about six or seven of us over lunch
Jeremy was part of that David hey do who
be moderating a panel later this
afternoon Paul Levitz other people other
people um and we talked it over and we
thought this was a great idea and the
the small committee of Jeremy Danny and
I was born and then a lot of lunches
ensued and it was during these lunch
talks that the idea grew from a panel to
a full day event to a two-day event next
time a week meanwhile in another part of
the forest known as Brooklyn chris
claremont wanted to donate his archives
to a university and his wife beth
contacted a mutual friend of hers in
mine who said you should talk to karen
green at columbia and so she did and i
was very excited and I went up to our
Rare Book and Manuscript library
director michael ryan because i'm not
allowed well I wasn't then allowed to
make this kind of decision alone a new
collecting area completely in rare books
and michael ryan was very interested and
he said let's pursue it and so he did
and once that process began it made
sense to publicize that acquisition
which is now in fact a done deal by
inviting chris to be featured in this in
this event which he will be this evening
this afternoon during the keynote so as
we had our talks we started with no
budget with no funds I was going to say
all we had was a dollar in a dream but
we didn't even really have a dollar so
we thought we should concentrate on
local talent which is not really a
limitation in New York City because you
can hardly throw a stone in the city
without hitting an aspiring or a
successful cartoonist so what was more
difficult was really narrowing it down
but I think what really drove our desire
to concentrate on comics and New York
was our deep love for this city for its
variety for its complexity for its
culture for its history and for its role
in the history of comics from I'm just
going to get a little pedantic here from
the first edition of the American
edition of The Adventures of Obadiah old
buck by Rudolf toepfer which is
published by brother Jonathan magazine
in 1842 right here in New York City the
same magazine which later published the
first comic book written in New York the
fortunes of Ferdinand flipper which you
can actually read for free online at the
dartmouth college digital library to the
circulation wars with the yellow kid to
spider-man swinging through the canyons
of our skyscrapers to will eisner xin
credibly evocative new york city
neighborhoods to local political
conflicts in world war three illustrated
to homey and intimate scenes in the web
comics of many of the people who will be
in panels tonight New York City is
always another character in the story of
the medium so the variety of ways to use
New York City and comics gave us a kind
of template of how we would organize the
panels and i think and i hope you'll see
that we've tried to look at very many
ways of of examining comics in new york
city we have mainstream people we have
alternative people we have webcomic
people we have people who work in
newsprint in magazines in web comics in
comic books and graphic novels because
this is a medium that can
legions and we're very lucky to love it
the way we do don't you think so comics
at Columbia just a couple of words it
was not a huge collecting area when I
proposed the collection although there
appears to have been a benevolent
librarian in like the 60s or 70s who
bought reprint collections we have for
example Crockett Johnson's Barnaby
strips in a nice reprint collection from
the 60s but when I proposed the
collection we really had three graphic
novels and I bet you can guess at least
two of them mouse Persepolis Palestine
these are on course reserves they were
assigned readings for classes now we
have almost 2300 titles and that's
titles not volumes because of course we
have multi-volume sets and these these
works are used from the School of the
Arts to the program in narrative
medicine and everything in between it's
widely used by by teachers for teaching
by students for research for senior
theses for masters essays and we hope
with the clermont archives we will be
able to take that into a new direction
with unique materials that people can
study as well and I do just want to say
that the library administration has been
insanely supportive of this from the
moment I first proposed it our VP of
information services our university
librarian jim neil has been an
enthusiastic and delighted supporter of
this direction so nothing is going to
change here anytime soon and as i said
now with the claremont archives we have
this whole new avenue of unique
materials scholars and students will be
able to come and consult his his notes
his drafts his correspondence his
character studies we even have a really
fabulous headshot of him from the 1970s
when he was an aspiring actor with long
flowing hair he laughed very hard when
he pulled that one out we packed them up
once the archives contents are processed
they will be available
a contents list called a finding aid
will be available online so from the
comfort of your home you can take a look
and see what we have and see if there's
something that you would want to consult
and that is a segue to the subtext of
this event which will now poke its head
deeply and prominently in to text which
is for those of you who have archives of
material your notes your drafts your
correspondence your character studies
etc if you would like to consider
columbia university is their final
destination we would welcome them
because there's no point in having
Chris's archives that they're lonely and
and solitary they need company so enough
from me I want to thank our sponsors
profoundly thank our sponsors because I
mentioned we started with no with no
funds whatsoever especially the Rare
Book and Manuscript library who
suggested sponsorship and support when I
was still trying to figure out how you
book a room on campus to university
programs and events for their incredible
generosity and all of these people are
listed on the back of your program to
Alexander Street Press a wonderful
electronic publisher who publishes a
database called underground and
independent comics they sponsored the
coffee service so drink up to colombia's
Institute for Israel and Jewish Studies
who's director has been promoting
amazing comics events on this campus for
the last couple of years that being
Jeremy to the big to DC and Marvel who
are inextricably part of the history of
comics in New York City to the American
Studies program a great friend to comics
in the curriculum and finally to the
willin and eyes and her family
foundation represented by the grabbers
who are here which commemorates the man
possibly most intimately identified with
comics and New York City will eisner we
didn't quite make this for Will Eisner
week which was the week of his birthday
march sixth but we're going to make this
will eisner month so there we go so a
round of applause for our sponsors
so we're going to get started with the
first panel I want you to enjoy
yourselves and I will try to do the same
thank you very much good morning
everyone my name is Chris Irving I'm
editor of graphic NYC NYC graphic
novelists calm as well as the new
digital comics magazine to draw inward
I'm here as the card tells us for New
York real and imagined whether you are
reading the make-believe worlds of the
yellow kid Superman the spirit horse
spider-man Bertha graphically documented
ones chronicled in the autobio of Art
Spiegelman d NASA you has fuel or Peter
Cooper New York City always takes stage
as a central character in comics how did
New York become so ensconced in the
cultural memory of the comics medium and
why do we keep going back to it why are
we held in thrall of the city
skyscrapers alleyways and streets with
the help of our five panelists we hope
to gather some insight into why New York
feels like the only city for the comics
medium our first guest is Ken twister
whose comics history work includes the
requisite book a comic study reader and
arguing comics both with cheat here Kent
is a professor of poly SCI at marymount
manhattan university he has also
authored CLR James a political biography
and the social science research council
1923 to 1998 and he is also the
co-editor of trade union politics
globalization's paradox let's please
give Kent a hand
thanks very much I've been speaking on
New York City and comics for the New
York Council for the Humanities for
about seven years and mostly at public
libraries and outer boroughs and Long
Island and occasionally at senior
citizen homes and the most interesting
question I ever got was from a very
sweet person who raised her hand and
said where's marmaduke from and I had to
say that was where my comics knowledge
ended and so if there's a Marmaduke
scholar or expert please let me know I'm
just gonna try to go quickly through
some very sort of key points about New
York City in comics hike actually finish
introducing everyone oh I'm sorry I have
like I have five slides dedicated to
Kent okay I'm so sorry Kent I should be
more clear next up he was scaring me
great so we get to your slides to do my
homework last night our next guest Molly
crabapple is the founder of dr.
sketchy's anti-art school which combines
cabaret with figure drawing her comics
work includes the webcomic backstage and
the graphic novel scarlet takes
manhattan both with co-writer john leave
it most recently Molly released the
artbook week in Hell which chronicles
recovering an entire room in original
artwork and she was also preparing for
the 2013 release of her graphic novel
straw house from first second books so
please give Molly a hand
I don't have a rude remarks prepared
next up is John Romita who came into
comics in the 1950s after graduating
from the manhattan school of industrial
arts mr. ramita did work for both marvel
than atlas comics and DC comics in 1965
john began working for the newly
christened marvel comics first drawing
daredevil and then taking over the
amazing spider-man from departing artist
Steve Ditko mr. ramita made spider-man
his giving a web head of veneer and a
shine he never had before and everything
from Peter Parker's more handsome look
despite he's more daring appearance
please please
following him is another john romita jr.
that is who is just as an imitated as
his father jr. broke out in the 80s
through his work on uncanny x-men Iron
Man daredevil spider-man and most
recently through his work on the
Avengers and the creator owned kick-ass
with Mark Miller not one to be outdone
John jr. has created his own legacy one
that stands right alongside his father's
I need to get less accomplished guests
next time because I'm running out of it
here finally Ariel shrugs autobio
cartooning he most recently be seen in
her web cop comic Ariel and Kevin invade
everything with writer Kevin cecia her
earlier works include the original
graphic novels awkward definition
potential and likewise Ariel is also a
writer on the HBO show how to make it in
america as well as the program the l
word since 2003 Ariel has taught the
graphic novel workshop at the new school
she is i'm proud to say even though i
never went here but i kind of wish i had
a two thousand three colombia graduate
with a degree in English literature so
please give Ariela Hannah hmm when
Superman first left tall buildings in
1938 Action Comics number one his home
city of Metropolis was obviously a
cipher of New York Kent you have some
Theory streaming from Superman's first
appearance as well as comics in New York
in general I think I already gave my
talk oh you're killing me okay I did
write out of talk the nexus of New York
and comics is multi-faceted complex and
profound we have certain basic ideas
that are often repeated and I want to
dig a little deeper
what we already know is that numerous
creators editors publishers work out of
the five boroughs in the larger
tri-state area we know that numerous
stories are set in New York real and
imagined and we know that New York City
itself its neighborhoods building's
architecture and so on serve as a kind
of character or an ensemble of
characters but to grapple with the
question of just how entangled the story
of comics is with the story of New York
City let's consider five images the
first comes from the early 30s from
Frank Kings gasoline alley it's a
wonderful panel that shows uncle Walton
skeezix taking a magic carpet ride over
Manhattan here we have the portrait of
the city through the eyes of a
Midwestern ER better to be up there than
down here it's a tourist perspective and
outsider's perspective as skeezix says
I'd hate to be one of those tiny ants
uncle Walt he's talking of course about
us this is suggestive of New York City
as the other and I think this is one
aspect of New York City and comics that
we don't often sort of call attention to
the way in which New York figures not
just in stories about New York but in
stories that are set in very different
places consider how often in Western
comics the villain or the fool comes
from back east I New York City and how
an archie comics Veronica's parents
returned from a new york city shopping
spree so the city is a point of
reference negative or positive sometimes
both in comics set in almost any
environment and can we move on to the
next one yes the second comes from
Superman number one summer 1939 Superman
is dangling a lobbyist over a telephone
wire emits dense skyscrapers but this
image is paradoxical if when I when I
show this image in the New York Council
talk I ask people where they think the
image is set or depicts and people might
guess Cleveland because they know where
Siegel and Shuster come from they might
say Toronto but the answer in the story
is Washington DC the one city where this
image is simply impossible and I think
that that is suggestive of a kind of
tendency to draw New York even when you
can't be drawing New York which is
another profound way in which New York
and comics intersect the third image
comes from the famous tragic story from
Will Eisner Who Karen mentioned the
story of Gerhard Schnabel the anonymous
New York City schlub who hopes to get
promoted that day after 20 25 years as a
sub janitor to the janitor position and
he gets shot just as he's about to show
everyone that he can fly because he has
the power flight but not the power of
invulnerability notice how the panels
and the composition as a whole invoked
the elevator shafts the verticality of
the skyscraper system a new hyper packed
environment that is only made possible
by science and technology by commerce
and capitalism a single tall building
it's important to remember is not a
skyscraper it's only when you have a
group of tall buildings clustered
together that you have skyscrapers and
so skyscrapers are part of a system and
many American comics are fixated on this
quintessentially modern 20th century way
of organizing urban space speaking of
superheroes it seems to me that the
superhero is a decades-long referendum
and I think schnabel is in a kind of
parodic failed superhero on modern life
as it's experienced in New York and
other large cities Superman tells the
optimistic case the immigrant can land a
good job at the center of the action
Batman explores the contrasting case
that even this wealthiest city residents
are overwhelmed by the forces of chaos
generated by the city's dysfunctionality
speaking of Des density we have this
fourth image by Jack Kirby I don't have
a date for it I pulled it off of google
images of course studies 50 yeah it's
loud at a tiny there before see it's a
translator and it was on my little
computer but here notice that he's
navigating the cosmos as if he's weaving
his way past tourists in Times Square if
you've ever traveled through space on a
surfboard and who hasn't you'll know
that space is pretty much empty but as a
true New Yorker Kirby can't help but
organized space both outer space and
inner space that is the space of the
page and
space of the cosmos rather differently
as a collision of objects all vying for
room all asserting themselves so that
the hero has to step lively and keep
moving so what is it they say can't you
can take the boy out of New York City
but you can't take the New York City out
of the boy you can take the surfboard
out of the Silver Surfer the final image
comes from the early 90s from a
four-part special Punisher series called
POV the book was written by jim Starlin
and drawn by bernie wrightson and this
page shows Frank Castle making his way
across the Hudson by a helicopter and
then swimming because the city's closed
to him the bridges and tunnels are full
police so he decides to jump out of a
helicopter since the police wouldn't
think to look in the sky and say who's
not falling out of a helicopter apart
from the sheer and practicality of
sneaking onto Manhattan this way what
strikes me about this page is the way in
which the panel's mimic the skyscraper
system I was talking about earlier which
brings me to my last point the grid
apart from density human density apart
from the density of architecture and the
skyscrapers one of the most distinctive
features of Manhattan is the way in
which it's organized around a series of
rectangular grid the grid system dates
back to the early 19th century and
represents an attempt not only to
control and regulate the development of
space in part to facilitate real estate
transactions but also as part of an
effort to improve public health by
clearing the air of insects and to make
a break with a European style of city
that features boulevards and crescents
in a traditional European city you
always know whether you're in a wealthy
neighborhood or in a poor neighborhood
by how much space there is between the
buildings or across the street sorry
that's fine so my only point is that New
York City is embedded in the history of
American comics thank you so much good
in one of the
something Kent and I were discussing
over coffee a couple weeks ago is how
New York works from either a
claustrophobic perspective or this great
wide open you know things are either
smaller if they're large basically so my
questions for the guests starting with a
John Romita and working towards me is
how do you use the claustrophobia or
scale and grandness of New York in your
work well my son is really the expert on
New York saying no no no I tried to
avoid as many bricks and windows as I
could have and I and in fact my
experience with new york city has been
to classic errors that everyone points
out in the history of comics my first
fight of man's story i had spider-man
swinging above the Empire State Building
and Stan was asked him by a fan letter
where was he swinging from and Stan said
from a helicopter of course all right by
second the second thing was on stand
that was my embarrassment second was
understand I did the death of Gwen Stacy
which is classic I had her falling from
the Brooklyn Bridge Stan wrote it as the
george washington bridge so Stan and I
both have a blush in New York history
but I tried to avoid as many buildings
as I could I did I used to do every
trick in the book including smoke and
and silhouettes my son does every window
in New York he probably knows every
building in New York by heart and he's
an expert on it but I will tell you that
spider-man New York City is a co-star
with spider-man the whole the whole
atmosphere and the fact that you have to
go through so many different directions
at one time you could see from the films
so the point is that New York City has
been since he since you Peter Parker was
raised in floor in forest hills and he
goes from Queens to New York every time
is amazing a lot of other people don't
don't bother with that kind of detail
but my son started to think when he was
nine years old at Peter Parker was a
neighbor of ours that's my that's my
connection with New York City in junior
no idea what the hell to say he covered
everything I i didn't i didn't have to I
didn't think of doing this it was part
of the job I had to do spider-man in New
York City and I had to use a lot i had
to get a library card to get reference
on the city itself he gave me some
photographs of manhattan and the city in
the 50s and i had to get referenced on
the city in the 70s and I remember I
love college I used i used the the
library at school when I left college I
didn't have a library card I had to go
there library card I went to libraries
and I got me graph copies of books you
know the smell made me graph that's back
when I was a token in mind that Louie um
and I had a reference on the twin towers
and Spiderman was battling a character
around the Twin Towers and it still had
that issue and it's it's very
uncomfortable to look at but I didn't I
had to bring spider-man I had to bring
the city into the book because it was
the job I didn't think of it as as part
of a greater scheme and it being a
character later on as i was doing
spider-man for the fourth or fifth time
I remember an editor telling me remember
this city is part is one of the
characters in spider-man and I said and
I didn't I wasn't nasty towards myself
of course it goes without saying but
that was the first time somebody had
actually said that to me and it I did
the the series with Straczynski right
and and it was ever-present the city and
but I was able to get the reference off
the internet as opposed to go into a
library and I remember think it was a
whole lot easier I didn't have to get
dressed up but I have stacks of my
morgue in in my office is endless from a
pre-internet days and now my stack of
internet photographs on cheap paper is
now
rivaling that I'm running out of room my
office and so they I was thrust into it
I didn't think of it and I just had to
follow along and when it became
important to you to do the city as a
character I really embraced it because
then everything I learned in college
everything I learned from him came into
play and suddenly design that the city
helped with the designs as opposed to me
having to design something the shape of
buildings in the shape of the skyline
helped me design something as opposed to
the other way around and one question I
have for you Junior because you're also
known for daredevil as well how is
Daredevils New York different from
spider-man's New York it's a much more
somber and moody look as opposed to
spider-man this spider-man more open
character and it seems like the editors
when I did daredevil always wanted the
scenes at night which is a little easier
but I also work with a writer who was a
very bohemian type of a ride on a man in
society who would fit into this
university perfectly and and we've
varied in our story lines it was animal
rights and so on but dead ova was always
in at night the character was always
based at night spider-man is much more
daytime and much more sunlight sunlight
I guess you could say just because it's
a no I said it's not important that it's
at night it's not a the costume doesn't
lend itself towards mood no daredevil
does hmm Molly um you were grab your
Webster peps actually um backstage in
your graphic novel scarlet takes
manhattan takes place in the early days
of burlesque in drawing this period New
York where did you turn and did you view
New York has a very claustrophobic place
or a very open area one of the big
references that I used first Carla Takes
Manhattan and backstage is Luke's antes
lowlife the lures and snares of old New
York which is his history of you know
tenements and criminality and political
machines the New York that I kind of
that most resonates with me and that i
grew up with isn't necessarily the New
York of like sweeping glass skyscrapers
and
saks fifth avenue it's the new york of
brownstones that never get really clean
where paint is just applied you know in
layers upon layers and there's curly
ironwork and there might be grand marble
fireplaces but there's graffiti on them
that sort of fractal hyper detailed
aesthetic is um something I use a lot in
my work and something that you see in
scarlet takes manhattan and in backstage
you see lots of brownstones and
cobblestone streets and as listening to
John he's talking about using smoke too
high buildings oh god yes so much smoke
the the smoking suit smoking sewers of
New York or the artists friend that's
how you know the city is meant for us
absolutely um but I don't just see New
York as as buildings or as architecture
i see New York primarily as the place
where broke kids come and with style and
grit and hustle and overwhelming work
they try to ascend to that point in life
when you have a washing machine in your
apartment so the New York that I draw is
very often the it's very often the stage
for crazy ambitious performers and
writers and artists and Bohemians and
that sort of tried to reflect in the
books and aerial you don't really set
your work in New York but you are a new
yorker most of your comics take place in
LA correct well my high school series
takes place in berkeley california where
i grew up and your current work is LA
not really okay all right well I
crunched that one then okay so but what
my question is is how does the New York
lifestyle inform your work when you sit
down um in order by oh well actually
yeah I think in my in my 12th grade book
likewise is about my senior year of high
school and I was completely obsessed
with New York I mean it was just I was
sort of one of those teenagers that just
sort of had this dream of moving to New
York and living in a basement and just
drawing comics non-stop and I was able
to follow that dream and the basement
flooded in everything so it was a it met
all of my tragic of fantasies and and in
in likewise you lack
it's funny when I'm they were talking
about the grid the sense of the grid
there's this one panel and I kind of
wish I'd given it to you but I didn't
think of it where there's just this I
just have this one image of a fantasy of
New York and it's just this completely
compact grid of buildings with like sort
of made up of little dots that are stars
and that was just sort of my image of
New York was just like a grid that was
like black with little dots of stars and
the stars are made of gold right yeah
exactly just wanted to clarify um and
you know then I can't I when I first
moved to New York it was I moved to Fort
Greene and I was kind of like this
doesn't look like New York but um but
eventually yes the the you know I did
sort of get to experience that vision
sort of traveling over the williamsburg
bridge and yeah i think for me like even
though i haven't drawn so many comics
that take place in New York just a few
short ones that sense of just the sort
of creative hub and dense sort of
devotion to whatever you're doing is
what I think of when I think of New York
wonderful yeah I was a little dismayed
and when I moved up here because I
didn't look a thing like friends you
cannot actually be an unemployed actor
and get an apartment off central park
what did I know anyways on to our next
question um we have three major
cartoonists Lisa my case I've you when I
think of New York our first cartoonist
is obviously will eisner when he first
drew the spirit in the 1940s the crime
fighter's home of central city was
obviously a New York cipher when will
created his first graphic novel a
contract with God in 1978 it presented a
seemingly more open new york as his
artwork had loosened up a bit with age
this page right years from his by
autobiographical kind of sort of memoir
the dreamer from 1986 next up is Jack
Kirby who grew up in the lower east side
and as we all know whom he helped define
the Marvel Age of comics with Stanley
the 1960s this is actually from Avengers
number four when Captain America comes
out of deep freeze and finds new york is
radically different and the yes the
hairdos how different they are
I totally loved that panel Jack went
ahead and gave us a glimpse into his
childhood in the lower east side in
street code from 1983 this is actually a
strike from his pencils as you can see
it's a much different type of New York
than the bright and shiny new york with
stars of gold and maude hairdos then we
see here finally thurs Frank Miller who
when he started with daredevil in the
late 70s I believe his elemental New
York very much combined the atmosphere
of a vice nurs with the power of Kirby's
with a lot of water towers thrown in for
good measure so my quest and of course
there's the dark knight returns that
famous splash and it's got them but we
know it's New York so my question for
each of the panelists actually we're
going to start with John and then work
our way back to kent because we're
running a little tight on time is um
well starting with John when you came to
Marvel in the 60s did you have any
direction to draw the Kirby New York or
did you rely more on drawing from the
New York outside your window I got no
instructions at all just the plot and
generally left to our own devices most
of what happens except if John is
getting a very definitive plot today I
never got definitive plots I got a half
hour of possibilities which half of them
slipped through my memory and I used to
go home and try to put patch together
what I thought we had decided to do and
I just made it up as I went along the
building's Jack Kirby's interesting
because you showed the lower east side
all of the bill all of the buildings and
the automobiles are like in the 30 is in
the late twenties Jack was drawing 1930s
automobiles into the 50s and I we used
to kid him about it used to say you know
they they have
fins on some of them well or you know I
Kirby couldn't drive if that might be
why one of the thing is he just only saw
things the way he originally envisioned
them and it was it was interesting
because he did you could see how he
modernized the Fantastic Four and all
you had to do is tip him and he would
immediately improve it I i was just
doing buildings that that i could get
away with a building that would
represent a new york city street and
with as little work as possible because
i was always late and so what that's the
only thing i could tell you deadline the
david john used to say is the deadline
style of art still see what comes out on
times that's a good segue into a John
jr. this splash panel is from daredevil
the man without fear I written by Frank
Miller it's actually um I was reading
this in my freshman year class I know I
shouldn't have been and I was an art
major and it's why I'm a writer now
because of this comic it was my first
discovery of John and amita juniors
daredevil with Al Williamson inks and
Frank Miller script uh so when you drew
off of a miller script and when you drew
daredevil it was a lot it was a huge
toll enormous no dialogue per se it was
just very little out just a lot of it
was it was a movie treatment that got
rejected that he decided to let me go
with and when he talks about little or
more I get scripts now but their hybrid
script says combination of platen script
whereas I used to get plots and it was
much more liberating getting plots even
something as extensive has something
from Frank and it was pretty much do
whatever you want just make sure
editorially it's the story and it
started out as 80 pages and it morphed
into 150 + 44 did it on my questions do
you do you feel that you had to refer to
Miller's New York to draw this or did
you still draw you know John Romita true
there was never that
information from him or and I never
thought of it that way I did it whatever
was in my head and I didn't think of it
I did at some point give Frank a couple
of images that he was familiar with
design-wise it interestingly enough
where I would think that this is what
Frank would do was stuff that we were
both doing when we start because we both
started the same time and Frank's
daredevil was ubiquitous at that time we
were doing this graphic novel but I
still gave it my my designs and he was
constantly telling me how much he
enjoyed it and at one point said I think
you did it first kind of thing this is
while he was doing a screenplay for
Robocop or something like that so he's
yelling at me via phone but he was so
much fun to work with because we pretty
much designed and story told the same
way so I worked out nicely yeah you guys
were just you worked hand-in-hand and
it's I mean I'm just going to fanboy out
for a sec but it's one of my favorite
comments ever but so so given your
current work on kick-ass 2 and Avengers
do you which New York do you did you
still do the what's the Chaon remuda jr.
New York the one that's out there right
now but it I've worked with a guy named
Mark Miller who was absolutely enamored
with all things new york and constantly
has me doing things in times square in
the middle of the day the most crowded
to cast a thousand yeah and it used to
bother me but now it's flattering
because they seem to think I'm the Cecil
B DeMille of comics
and it's annoying and I usually have to
get take more time but everything I do
is based in New York and I'm just so
used to it now that we're as I began
with images and reference on the city
now I design the the illustrations and
get details after the fact know what I
can do things without having the
reference unless it's a specific
specific location I can do it without
referencing photographs and that's fun
but then I'll always go back to I'll put
up an image a double spread image
photograph on my desk on my drafting
table just to give me a little flavor
and so again I I've done it so often and
now I'm doing it so much presently with
kick ass and even with the Avengers it
doesn't I don't need to begin with
photographs I i use it afterwards for
the finishing awesome and next on to
Molly this is a page from Webster
backstage and now interestingly enough
with your work Molly I don't really see
a curvy I don't really see an eisner I
don't see a miller i see a richard
outcault yellow kid which that's a
little yeah it's not the best image I'm
afraid but you know I see the alleyways
teeming with people you know climbing
over one another shoving and just tell
me where you get your new york from I
think I get my artistic style from Bosch
more than any other and any other artist
but I'm where do I get my new york from
i think i'm thomas nast political
cartoons a scathing scathing satire I'm
pitifully uneducated about comics it's
one of my shameful admissions that I
think I'm making here for the first time
so so I come to things more from the
historical illustration perspective for
backstage I just wanted to get every
single type of person I could find in
New York from like rich bankers to
prostitutes to you know two people
running fake opium dens that were aimed
at Mid Western tourists and shove them
all into the same canvas so that if you
just stared at it for a while you could
keep finding new things awesome I have
another
quick yes quick I just thought of
something relatively intelligent I grew
up watching films with my father
everything seemed to be based in New
York City was all buildings whether it
was a pin Costello movies or anything
else cops and robbers movie was
Manhattan I started comics and it was
Manhattan I'm from the Sun born and
raised in the city queens it's
ever-present in my life even when I
lived in California all i had was
reference on the city so it comes from
the fact i'm it and it's me it's in your
DNA it's i think it is really in our
cultural I don't come from the head I
don't come from the Lower East Side to
come from far rockaway actually um no
it's totally true sometimes I feel like
I look at people from New York and I
feel like we're like viperfish or angler
fish or one of those fish from the deep
ocean that if you take it up to the lab
it kind of explodes because it was
because he was bred to be young it was
bred to exist under extreme pressure um
sometimes I look at how claustrophobic
my panels are and I think of the first
apartment that I had in New York which
was one room no windows three roommates
divided up by shower curtains and and
we'd paid six hundred dollars a month
because we want to live in Manhattan and
you know I would work with my eye I
didn't really even have a table I would
just sort of work with my like little
painting propped up against the wall in
this dark room and I'd have to draw
small because there was no room to do
anything bigger and you just try to try
to cram everything in cuz that that's
you know that's how we are were crammed
in here that is great yeah the
apartments are so much smaller here than
than where I used to live to get me
started all right Ariel this is actually
Columbia set strip correct
freshman at Columbia and um yes I
punched someone in the face at Barnard
and was actually banned from the bar
nerd campus for two years that is
awesome the things you learn when you do
panels um but yes if it this story yeah
basically a minute involved alcohol big
surprise um it also had just involved
the concept of a gay prom which to me is
so wrong and like the fact that also
like you know a lot of these you know we
weren't allowed to be gay at our prompts
in high school so then you like finally
get one at college and you had all this
pent-up bitterness and just like turns
into a fight literally someone called
told my friend that she was the most
irritating person she'd ever met and so
then I decided to avenge her it's
actually very comic like there was a lot
of like vengeance and so was it one of
those situations where it's like okay
man there's gonna be two hits me hitting
your face you hitting to vote it was
exactly that it was sort of me being
like yeah we're gonna kick your ass my
friend me like I got you back got your
back we like went around and like
rounded up back up around the dance
listen basically it ended up in my
friend totally getting her ass kicked
like seven butch dykes punching her and
kicking her with steel-toed boots and I
like rolled off somewhere and was like
trying to fix my glasses which is like
sort of come loose a woman of your
education this is I know right you know
I had a question for but I just I don't
know if I can follow that it's but yes
it the whole comic takes place on the
Barnard and columbia campus and in my
Columbia John J dorm room uh yeah um
that's it that is just incredible okay
well I actually have a question
how much did the New York culture and
living in New York and go into Columbia
inform your future work whether it's uh
I'm sorry I think a little light-headed
I laughed a bit too hard whether it's
set in California or anywhere else said
it in a room in any city um well I
actually would really love to draw more
comics about New York I do have one
comic a short comic in process called my
troubles with glasses about trying to
buy a new pair of glasses and basically
going to all the different lens crafters
in the city after if they got knocked
off during this is this is after I've
graduated college so I'm just like
living in Williamsburg and don't have a
job so instead like fuel all my energy
into buying a new pair of glasses and
yeah basically just would sort of keep
kept returning the glasses into it to
every lenscrafters so then felt shamed
and couldn't go back so kind of went to
like seven different glasses stores in
New York so you kind of see me traveling
throughout New York um through the theme
of glasses but there is one scene
actually that reminds me of some of the
images we've seen here tonight where I'm
going to pick up like I don't know like
the fifth pair of glasses or something
and I'm just full of shame and horror my
sister is driving me and I know I'm
gonna have to return them I just have
this feeling and all sound like the sky
just turns dark and we look up and it's
like this we're like apocalypse like one
of those just weird sort of north or
it's called like a nor'easter something
like it's just like dark it like
completely black it like 3pm and it's
just me looking at but like the sort of
skyscrapers like sort of zooming in and
you know this rain crashing down and to
me that was I'm sort of very classic New
York moment feeling sort of overwhelmed
by the city um thank you thank you and I
have one question for Kent you know when
comics started in the 1930s comic books
I should specify New York really was we
still are at the hub but New York was
where all comics came from you had to
live in New York if you wanted to do
comic books there was no fedex and so
forth that's probably a big part of why
New York is so ingrained in the American
comic book as we become more globalized
Kent do you see New York losing its
place as
the city of honor be it a cipher or the
actual New York City that's a hard one
I'm I'm still sort of digesting all the
great things have been said I think we
should run Ariel for mayor I think I you
know I would hate to have to follow up
her answer I think that just the the
glasses the gay prom she could she could
like drop lobbyists from from telephone
lines yeah I was gonna say power lines
but I just learned we don't have power
lines New York I never noticed it till
someone mentioned it yeah i mean just
quickly i mean it is one of those
industries that didn't decamp i mean it
didn't flee to the suburbs obviously
there are people who transmit their work
electronically and and there is a sort
of inevitable dispersion to some extent
but you know it's striking how the
companies have largely remained in New
York and you know occasionally on the
web you'll see somebody say who Eugene
Oregon we have so many cartoonists and
you know there are streets in Brooklyn
that a more cartoonists than a Eugene
Oregon I mean the whole Pacific
Northwest hails in comparison to what
certain sections of the city have to
offer I mean at one point the city had
three museums devoted to comics one of
which was sort of a dodgy enterprise one
of which was about to move and mocha
which is what celebrating its 10th
anniversary and to the 11th so it seems
like mocha this conference and maybe
future Columbia related conferences
collections I mean I think there's a lot
of ways in which New York can remain at
the center of the story of comics for
four decades to come I work with Mark
Miller Mark Miller works about five
other artists and they're all from
different countries Philippines Scotland
and each of them have worked that's
based in the city new york city and i
get copies that they work by the
internet and because of the reference
that you can get in
thing and everything it's spot on and
these guys have never been to the city
in some cases so yeah it still is since
it will be as long as you can just hit
the enter key you get the reference I
did I Daniel remember this I did
unfortunately I did a job with a writer
I won't mention any more but I had to do
it in Pittsburgh you know I'm talking
about it was Irving for Bush wasn't it
now and that wasn't the problem it's
Brooks over a city but I had a reference
on Pittsburgh and I got the reference
for wherever I got it I forgot where I
got it from and in order to make it look
like Pittsburgh I had to use the bridges
but when the three rivers meet and I
began it and I said I'm gonna two
bridges this is a pain in the ass so I
did buildings and to get the distinction
between the building architecture in
Pittsburgh and Manhattan is very subtle
and it's not easy to distinguish so I
even put Pittsburgh hall of fame on a
wall somewhere I have no idea i had to
do something that because the writer was
mad at me said this doesn't look like
Pittsburgh looks at me in Hatton it's I
could give me a give me a location and
he gave me something well how you want
to do something to come and was such a
pansy about it my point is that it's
such a subtle difference between cities
go to the architecture and unless you
put in the Three Rivers and it's all of
those bridges it it's a subtle
difference and I was not gonna do that
but again it looked like the city it
looked like New York City to me when I
was done hmm even though it was
Pittsburgh architecture even the writer
couldn't tell the difference Wow New
York's in your blood it's inescapable
well that about wraps up my section um
I'd like to open the floor to any
questions
so oh it's right there by that projector
I was lucky enough or I'm lucky enough
to live right next to occupy wall street
and when that first started happening I
would go down pretty much every day with
my iphone camera and take pictures of
the protesters and just a people you
know doing stuff there and do sketches
of them that was my first time doing
like real serious repertory of New York
and yeah it's really it's really
rewarding to get to do that helps your
style a lot the only time I ever did it
was when I was single I gentleman by the
name of Morimoto who is an older man
when I met him told me the best way to
meet women is to go to a bar and
roselyn's go to location a restaurant or
bar and draw and I did it and he was her
he was right so nothing so nothing so
classy as I want to draw images of
people I was trying to meet women but
the flipside is that it is impossible to
draw on a bar as a woman like you just
someone will come up to you yes Joe
let's show nobody came up to me I had to
go up to people who could i'm drunk
when I was 17 I got a job at a little
otago fee sorry i was working at forbes
lithograph doing coke Cola bottles at
lunch time I took a publisher's dummy a
hardcover book no no sketch pad and I
did drawings of drunks asleep in Bryant
Park I did people sunning themselves
with the reflectors I the drawings of
little children I just one drunk had I
have about 10 drawings of him he always
had one shoe off he was out on his face
cold and the shoe is always like five
feet away from and I drew him like in
every angle possible I did the arch
behind Brian park I did some of the
buildings i did put the back of the
library and i did hundreds of drawings
stray cats whatever i could but i also
used to carry it around and I delivered
packages when I was 15 I delivered
packages all through Times Square and up
to 57th Street I used to deliver and I
carried it with me and when I was
waiting for a bus or or just in in a
doorway waiting for rain to stop I would
draw people wherever they were he did
stuff at that age that I can't do now
yeah I still have some of those drawings
I've got to miss the compliment as a
teenage at 15 he was doing things that a
lot of artists actually I was better
than the night that I have was home it's
true I'm true I still have those but I
gave away multivitamin distort I gave
them away but I kept those sketches go
figure
we have time for some more questions
camper
that's the topically you alluded to that
anything that happens newsworthy is
going to change a story or the way you
draw 911 changed the way I drew things I
had do a spider-man issue based on it
and it changed things you're right
surveillance police ever-present no
longer the Twin Towers to draw but I'll
be able to do Freedom Tower so it
changes according to news according to
events I think the point about
surveillance is really interesting and
it's also a two-way surveillance if I
was depicting New York I might draw
people now I might draw people
constantly staring into their iPhones
and capturing and capturing everything
around them it's like we're being
watched but we're watching also and this
constant to a feat of the robot I i
would just quickly say that i think that
the rivers are becoming more important
that when i first moved to New York very
few people spend time around water and I
think that you know there's a
possibility that sometime this century
water will become a sort of threat to
parts of New York through flooding but
the access to the water so much greater
do you think that's because maybe
facilitar partly and of course you know
150 years ago water was where immigrants
came and diseases and so on and that's
why Fifth Avenue and Madison were sort
of the wealthiest areas because it was
the furthest from the waterfront and
there's been a sort of tendency now to
move in the other direction where the
waterfront is now though some of the
most valuable property
this is actually kind of a follow-up to
the previous two questions and it is
more focused for the room ITA's when
you're dealing with a pre-existing
continuity coming in and dealing with it
and with the time compression that goes
in with the stories of these characters
who are you know a quarter of the age
that they're really supposed to be you
have you have a changing face of New
York and how do you deal with that for
instance you know with daredevil being
the protector of Hell's Kitchen it's
like do Chelsea theatergoers you know
really need their own protector you know
and delancey street today is not you
know the Yancy Street of Ben Grimm's
youth and that sort of thing and you
know I I found it amusing when they
replaced daredevil briefly with the with
them Black Panther it's like you you
have the the lower the upper middle
class people being protected by a
defrocked King it's like how do you deal
with it with with the inherent
anachronism of this of New York not
being New York today not being the New
York that of these characters
backgrounds just follow as things change
and get updated reference deeper than
that the right of my hat we've got but I
don't that honestly as an artist design
is designed and then you just update
your images as far as new buildings or
for instance Times Square has changed so
drastically since I began in the
industry that maybe that was a major
amount of reference and now the way
businesses come and go and buildings
changed because of that I am a little
stickler for details I will get like I
said the stack of reference i have is
getting its getting mine
that's it's an aesthetic with me just
have to change as the city itself chains
which is kind of exciting I will sir i
will add one thing one of the things
that we were talking about intent and
and proactive influence of the city one
of the main things that stand and i
always paid attention to us we were we
were not reporters and journalists we
were like a mirror reflecting the
culture as it was in 65 and in 75 and an
85 has that mirror we were just saying
this is the way it was then and and
stands only other orders were I don't
want anything done in 85 to look like it
was done in 75 so the city's growth is
automatically built into our plot and
artists arrangement and we try not to
create as much as reflect kind of adding
on to that I grew up in the 90s that's
when I was really reading comics and I
feel like kind of the Frank Miller
daredevil Hell's Kitchen New York was
kind of like kind of head and arrested
development in the 90s because of the
the kind of dark grim and gritty comics
that were coming out so when I actually
moved up here when I first came to New
York even I was expecting it to be like
the New York the 80s action movies and
you know above the very violent comics i
had read you know with people with
gritted teeth all the time and it's not
but I feel like that New York has kind
of kind of got stuck for a little while
for maybe a decade longer than it needed
to be but that's just my two cents
that's true and I think I think a lot of
people like Frank Miller and in a little
bit of a little bit more of the grime
and the and the darkness of it
of course felices when he started when I
started that's when the city looked like
in the seventies well I think he added a
little level to it when he did the
artwork and also joe quesada had the
same kind of oven he would add a layer
of religious and and cultural clashes
that would give you the idea that every
every street corner is a battleground in
eagle so the thing is John and I I think
look at the sunny side of things then
Frank Miller and joke is another that's
all I can tell you that's going dead
yeah I did him smiling and he didn't
pouty i'm working with howard chaykin
i'm working with howard shakin on a
crater on project based on two
characters that grew up with my parents
names muggy and bimbo and i went to
Howard shaken with the story and it was
going to be in the 40s how shaken
preferred to make it into the 70s
because we both grew up as single guys
in the 70s and he said it's a it was
much more interesting visually than in
the city is now and there's varying
degrees of that opinion there were
people that say that time square looks
like Disneyland now compared the way it
was which is true and Howard Chaykin is
one that believes the city was much more
interesting visually in the 70s than it
is now I don't necessarily agree but
it's much more interesting to draw but
it's along the lines of what Frank
drooling and daredevil yeah it was like
a foursome went to Hell's Kitchen I'm
like wow this is a pretty happy place
that's our next question I have a
question for John senior I grew up
reading your comics and when I actually
moved out here I come from a small town
on the west coast when I came out here I
was absolutely shocked to realize that
water towers were real you don't we made
them up I I assume that I think someone
at some point explain to me what they
were but I couldn't believe that they
were the structure is real but earlier
you mentioned having to make deadlines
in the simplest way of drawing a
building yet in your comics you seem to
lavish a lot of attention on water
towers so I'm curious as to why you know
I'll tell you I think that's a reaction
Murray seven was a colleague of mine for
about 20 years at Marvel we worked
together at the office and she was very
critical and she used to always upset my
apple cart she considered that I did New
York apropos of our RF subject matter my
new york was like it was just finished
no bricks were were damaged there are no
cracks in the sidewalk there was no
debris honest on the curbs Maurice
Maurice vision of New York was a filthy
place she lived in Queens and to her
Manhattan was a pigsty and and if I
didn't put a crack on every corner in
every street corner and and dent some
cars she used to say you your street in
your city looks like it was just built
like a Disney version so she always
really killed me so I ended up having to
do water towers more grimy and more
dingy and dented and and ugly because
she asked me to do it that's so I'm just
a visitor just a victim of the following
order she's making a grid when i was
first drawing backgrounds it was just
simple squared off buildings and he told
me break it up with a couple of fires in
water towers and it was a revelation it
was a design revelation it was all of a
sudden instead of square tops of
buildings it was the angle of some
buildings simplicity citicorp building
NL so the water towers was something a
new tools but do you see you see the
shot that Frank Miller did he had like
five water towers with it could have
been one he just loved the fact that he
was getting all the variety
so what I would debate whether New York
was really sanitized I think what's
happened is that it's moved off of the
streets non to Craigslist um you know I
think that I think that everything
sorted and everything that people are
nostalgic about happens now it just
happens behind closed doors and to
richer people Jan Morris wrote a book
called Manhattan 1945 on the cover is a
photograph of people at a nice you know
night club then I looked at the small
print the photo was taken in 1943 those
people could be dead by 1945 so that got
me very angry but it was a comment that
Jan Juarez made that was amazing I never
thought of it said basically New York
hasn't didn't change from 1920's to 1950
we think of it as a dynamic place but
technically the politics was about the
same the habits of the people about the
same the ethnic because of the
immigration stoppage about the same the
streets there wasn't that much thing so
i think that the comic books really had
an advantage there that they could
really have a recognizable like 30 year
period where that's New York and
everybody in the world knew it yeah
actually it is I was just going to say
we have about two minutes left so if
someone's ready to go with the question
yeah um I know this focus was more on
you could say like the more street level
and like higher up level of New York I
was wondering what how do you perceive
like almost you could say the pastoral
element in New York which are the parks
and stuff like the High Line and also
the underground I've always viewed the
subway system as the sort of hair shirt
of New York City the this sort of fowl
intestine that we have to plunge
ourselves into as you to give us
humility from living in such a sparkling
silver babylon
Shh she's full of metaphors sound this
is awesome um so yeah I think that the
filth of the filth and grime and
graffiti of the subway is an awesome
subject that's great we're actually out
of time so i would love to thank
everyone for being here i would love to
thank the panel we will we will have we
have a table set up in the hallway for
if you want to buy some books and get
them signed by all five of our amazing
panelists oh thanks again if this was
great
you